what do you think about zuckerberg
what i think of mark zuckerberg yeah
what do you think the ceo of facebook
yes ceo of meta now have you heard that
about this i haven't they changed the
name of the company yesterday
to meta they changed the name of
facebook to meta
yes i don't know if it's cl i don't know
if it's like a parent company i don't i
don't know if that's clear yet but they
did they rebranded to meta because
they're trying to build the metaverse
and i thought it'd be fun to watch this
video of mark uh
inside the metaverse siva pointed out
how [ __ ] like how poetic is it that
the dude who is so vilified for selling
metadata changes the name of his company
he just does not understand humans yeah
i mean one bit i imagine him in the
metaverse having long ass hair
like blobby oh blonde hair and he comes
out hi i was just smoking meats in my
pyramid
exactly like smoking smoking
because he doesn't even get that part of
having long hair
like mark in his metaverse would make
himself hot but like we would know it's
mark because he wouldn't behave hot yeah
i think that like hi
make it he'd make himself look the exact
same because i feel like he thinks he
looks very good right now that's true
yeah he's like very modest but
respectable yeah yeah everyone else
tries to be something else and he's the
only one like mark dude god yeah that's
his username yeah
god
for people that don't know what the
metaverse is
i think this video describes it
perfectly
are you coming
yeah
just gotta find something to wear pause
what
that is
what the [ __ ] what's that what a start
for a video are you coming i wish you
would have looked around the camera yeah
are you coming just yeah
this is such a god complex i love it him
looking back at his [ __ ] ps2
character
this is so good hi mark hello mark
right
hi mark i could be
here this is just him like waving his
dick like nintendo sue me i can make we
me's too yeah exactly yeah you ain't
[ __ ] nintendo you really nailed the
hairline on the
emoji oh no i love how pale and shitty
is like that they did not
no he wanted it that way any justice
league how many animators he beat with a
belt to get that color tone correctly
yeah yeah
[Laughter]
jesus christ okay
we can't go we can't go anymore it's
zero it's already zero
going to the negatives
glow make me glow hey let's see what the
[ __ ] yeah sorry no you're fine
look no start from the beginning are you
coming i don't hear that coming again
hey are you coming yeah you gotta find
something to wear
yeah yeah yeah
it's gotta be on the soundboard
all right perfect
oh hey mark hey what's going on
what's up
whoa we're floating in space who made
this place it's awesome right it's from
the crater i met in l.a uh this place is
amazing
what the [ __ ] is this i was i when i
texted you yesterday i was just watching
this
thinking like this is just so far from
what it actually would be yeah like the
real metaverse like on vr you pop into
this and you're like
[ __ ] and it's like just like complete
have you ever been on vr chat it's just
like a dude who's like check out my tits
and then all his friends is like
screaming yeah those friends is like
[ __ ] up like mickey mouse's that are
like three pixels tall like humping his
leg like dude give me some give me some
bruh give me something
i just don't even know what the [ __ ] i'm
looking
it's like first off do they like where
you at she said i'm in la he's like
we're floating in space who made this
she said a creator i met in la what a
[ __ ] marketing line to the team we
want to showcase that we have creators
from the coolest places who chooses who
chooses to be bald in the metaverse
[ __ ] bozo bro
this is quite the collection of friends
for sure they've been bald like you got
someone on this
the [ __ ] uh sex like registry and
then you have you have ramona flowers
and a [ __ ] gobot yeah table it's like
what what kind of friend group is this
dude he's like sorry i'm late guys he's
like who are you meeting who are these
people what the [ __ ] are you what is
this can you imagine that bald guy
blinking into the room just like
everyone's like yo
what it's funny that even in the
metaverse being bald would be negative
yeah i'm saying like it's it's like yo
who the [ __ ] did you invite this guy no
i don't know who he is
real quick i'd stop in
you logged in bald
maybe you want to bounce man the last
world i was in i randomly selected and
it put me in a playground and legally i
can't be within 15 feet so
i don't know why he has mark's voice too
everybody in this universe is mark
it's all of his dark thoughts let this
go what happens from here of course it's
me you know i had to be the robot man i
thought i was supposed to be the robot
you are the robot mark oh nice joke mark
you guys you guys
i thought i was supposed to be the robot
yeah that that's pretty you can
yeah it'd be funny if there was also a
lizard at the table he's like i thought
i was also supposed to be the reptilian
then it would then he like looks
directed at the camera and he's just
like
that would be funny it'd be all right
cute yeah he's like
are you coming yeah just got to find
something to wear puts on his outfit it
just goes into bohemian grove it's just
[ __ ] a goat being sacrificed that's
hillary clinton bill clinton oh
dude
illuminati like i yeah
do you know how successful that campaign
would be oh dude if he went in and he's
just like hold it down like really
aggressive hold down it's like people
chanting and [ __ ] and he like rips out
and he's like
yeah i would sign back into facebook
[Laughter]
and just like eats the guts yeah exactly
yeah everyone will reactivate facebook
they're like dude mark's cool yeah yeah
my grandma who still used to probably be
a little upset that's fine
culture flip we take all the current
take it but people yeah we take it back
we reclaim it and we take all the
current facebook people and relegate
them to like i don't know
linkedin boards or something no but
they're still on facebook this is meta
this is true this is first of all yeah
yeah yeah millennials yeah all right let
this go
hey wait where is naomi let's call her
naomi
hey should we deal you in sorry i'm
running late but you've got to see what
we're checking out what's up jordan
what's going on
hiding ar pieces for people to find
3d street art that's cool send that link
over so we can all look at it
no one would ever say funny
no one would ever say british
street
it's disappearing this is amazing hold
on i just love this i love how like
marketing person this is yeah it really
is what can we do that like no one would
actually want to do these things you
can't i wish
you had somebody [ __ ] about it like
floating around they're like oh
pole guns are kind of low like low cut
like people would be complaining yeah
yeah pulling around this looks [ __ ]
stupid is just tubes yeah yeah yeah yeah
3d art yes i don't know why
also the funny thing about vr that they
never acknowledge is the [ __ ] motion
sickness have you ever watched someone
like
like i got my valve index and we're
gonna break it in on stream and they're
[ __ ] five minutes in and they're like
i have to sit down yeah like it's not
you're not gonna be floating in 3ds
flying around an optical illusion that
or if it was the same commercial be cut
back to mark and he was just like
sitting on his couch like
yeah do you think yeah like i would be
excited i would also accept that too
he's just like smiling kind of like
whimpering a little bit
no see that's too real that would be
endearing
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
yeah
it's not going to spit on itself hit on
it i can feel that check out this forest
room
huh let's see
koi fish that fly that's new
this is wild
hey one sec boss it's priscilla hey you
have to see this beast is going crazy
oh i love that guy you're [ __ ] about
your dog i'm in the [ __ ] medicine
it's going crazy
right now i don't care about your dog
you're getting your microphone
look at rocco isn't he running around
all crazy
hey hey hey are you coming i sure am i'm
about to yeah
yeah i i hate the idea that anyone could
call me at any time to send me a video
of their [ __ ] dog i don't care yeah i
don't know it's like you go to the
metaverse to get away from that [ __ ]
yeah not to be the worst part of
facebook yeah baby pictures since we
have a picture they're blocked but you
know what this is this is what it's
gonna take to bring like vr chat to like
the regular world facebook's owns oculus
right yeah okay yeah yeah
so
it's gonna happen has his paws and just
about everything doesn't yeah